our shout out tonight to all the
reporters who this week were awarded
Pulitzer Prizes and for the Pulitzer
committee itself which this year chose
to honor a select group of reporters who
did not win
before I announce where they are I want
to break with tradition and offer my
sincere admiration for an entry that did
not win but that should give us all hope
for the future of journalism in this
great democracy the entry is from the
staff of the Eagle Eye student newspaper
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
in parkland Florida which submitted the
obituaries of 17 coaches and classmates
who were killed during a tragic shooting
in their school in February 2018 the
eagle eyes submission stated that the
student reporters and editors had to
quote put aside our grief and recognize
our role as both survivors journalists
and loved ones of the deceased end quote
these budding journalists remind us of
the media's unwavering commitment to
bearing witness even in the most
wrenching of circumstances in service to
a nation whose very existence depends on
a free and dedicated press there is hope
in their example even as security
threats to journalists are greater than
ever and there is hope even if some
wrongly degrade the media as the enemy
of the very democracy it serves of
course the press will endure because as
the founding fathers knew well there can
be no democracy without it
that is something Rebecca Smith wendy
Winters
robbed hyacinth Gerald Fishman and John
McNamara understood too they understood
it when they went to work last June at
the Capitol Gazette in Annapolis
Maryland and were gunned down by a
madman who opened fire in their newsroom
it is what Jamal could show he
understood as well when he bravely wrote
truth to power at the Washington Post
before being murdered in October 2018
inside the Saudi consulate in Turkey in
all 63 professional journalists
worldwide were killed this year
according to reporters without borders
that is a 15% increase in journalists
who lost their lives for simply trying
to do their jobs and their spirit this
year's winning work reflects yet again a
steely resolve in upholding the highest
principles and ideals of this noble
profession a sobering and important
reminder that's our program for this
week we'll see you back here again next
week good night
you